um you've obviously sort of set out this
this failure to this this lack of
curiosity
in the the threat to our democratic
processes
um well obviously ministers have
questions to answer
about that do you also think that the
spy chiefs
the the spy masters who are in charge of
the agencies
should have been more forceful in
gripping what you describe as a hot
potato
and getting to the bottom of whether or
not there was actually russian
interference in the brexit referendum
primarily this is a political question
should the government have instructed
this work to be undertaken and the
answer is
yes of course it should have as to the
question about
heads of agencies only mi5 can self-task
and direct work itself the other
agencies would require to be
asked to do it so yes
mi5 perhaps should have done this work
but more importantly and i think you led
off very
cleverly the lack of curiosity
particularly after the dnc
hack and leak episode one would have
assumed
someone at the heart of government might
have wanted to know
if the efficacy of democratic processes
in the uk
was being undermined if the squadron
messages were being amplified
if there was an attempt to actually
change the result that work
has not been done
i think there's quite rightly i think in
our democracy
a reluctance for the securities of
directly getting involved in the
political process i think that's a given
but i think what is not excusable here
as stuart has just outlined that no one
in government in terms of ministerial
level or above actually looked at
uh the uh you know flashing lights that
were there already in terms of the
scottish
referendum and the
issue in terms of the democratic party
in the united states
and that is a political question um you
know and
that is one that needs should have been
looked at
and in terms of failures
that is a major failure because we say
in the report would
if we discovered for example uh
interference could we have quantified
its effect on elections
no we couldn't i don't think you could
but at least i think we could have
actually known
what the threat was but also
measures in the future we could take to
mitigate against those threats
debra have another go thank you
um obviously you can't say categorically
whether or not there was russian
interference
in the brexit referendum but given all
the evidence that you have heard
what is your best guess do you believe
that russia did try to influence that
vote
and just a second follow-up if i may um
you talked about how
that standard government line that we've
heard so many times that there's been no
evidence of successful
interference do you believe that that
was the government being deliberately
evasive
to avoid the fact that they don't they
just simply don't know because they
haven't looked
well i'm not sure if it was being
evasive or if it was trying to just be a
little
too cute and as kevin said it would be
impossible to quantify
the impact of interference so in the
sense that
it's impossible to prove whether that
interference had been successful
or otherwise the key point though when
you allude to in your question they had
not sought
even to ask that question and that's at
the heart of this report
deborah i think the the question is this
is
and i think there's obviously a
misunderstanding of the role of this
committee
we deal with evidence uh we have
extensive powers including access to
some of the most
highly uh classified and secret material
uh that is available to uh government
there was no evidence uh that we saw and
the reason why there was no evidence
because no one had actually
asked for the work to be done so in
terms of
saying did russia interfere in the eu
referendum
uh you can't say that but no one in
government asked
that either so on the evidence we saw
i think uh we became a conclusion
that uh we can't make a judgment call
and stuart's right even if
there had been an investigation into it
quantifying the effect of that actually
on
the result would be would be very
difficult but we saw no evidence because
there was no evidence
and government no one in government
sought to look or ask the questions
uh that needed to be asked one more
deborah
well i mean given that that's your
finding are you now going to do are you
demanding that they do go and look
and find out and will you as a as a
committee be in be following up this
inquiry and investigating and finding
out conclusively
whether or not russia did influence in
our democratic events like the
referendum
well we cannot ask the agencies
to do work we can only ask them to tell
us what they already know
but it's self-evident from the
publication of this report the
government should now
sit up and pay attention and we have
welcomed as i said
the work that they appear to have done
in relation to 2019
but we've yet to see the evidence of
that
what we've also said is that the
committee will
now look at any evidence which comes
forward
in relation to what's happened 2019 and
beyond
and i would also we would also agree and
it's in the report
with the dcms select committee which has
made a similar request to government in
the past
that it should try to understand the
scale and nature
of the interference in previous
electoral and democratic events
what i would say is this is we had a
written ministerial statement last week
suggesting that uh from a
from the foreign secretary suggesting
that uh russia interfered
in the 2019 uh general election
we have seen no evidence of that be
because we've not been provided
with any of the intelligence which
supports that
statement we've asked to see it
but the important point here i think is
that in terms
of the protecting the democratic process
uh lessons should have been learned or
at least the question should have been
asked and they weren't
so if uh the report is very clear
we suggest government should now do it
but as stuart said we can't task
the agencies or anywhere else to
undertake this review
you